this episode of congratulations is
brought to you by blue apron blue aprons
mission is to make incredible home
cooking cooking cooking not clipping
incredible home cooking accessible to
everyone
featured upcoming meals include crispy
chicken tenders and mashed potatoes
pasta and creamy tomato sauce so check
out this week's menu and get your first
three meals free at blue apron dot-com /
Congrats that's blue apron dot-com /
congrats to get your first 3 meals free
blue apron a better way to cook this
episode of congratulations is also
brought to you by the cash app you know
the cash app because you're a baby and
you get it this is simple it's the
simplest way to instantly send money to
friends it's also the number one app in
finance if you don't know now you know
but it didn't get their own payments
alone these days cash app is changing
how people interact with their money
it's adding features you can only get
from a bank and more than a few that you
can't like the cash card boosts and
bitcoin download the cash up for free on
the App Store or Google Play market
[Music]
what's up what's up my babies dude it's
me it's me the cult leader Chris D'Elia
and we're here with episode 86 on
congratulations did we ever think we'd
get to 86
we had an inkling but we weren't sure
now I'm here live on my app I'ma be on
my app a little bit now here's the deal
dude
I got these got these look what daddy's
wearing dude the Grand Slam tea and I
gotta tell you it's a size too small but
it's the one I got and it's the one I'm
gonna wear and we're we're reopen on
those in the merch store like you know
any day now so when you see this uh-huh
you want to serve [ __ ] fresh piping
hot Grand Slams then you go and you get
this [ __ ] dude I've been seeing people
with these shirt that come out I saw
four people come out the other day in
shirts to my show and the scheduling
conflict couldn't go feel really bad but
um I never can sigh hate canceling shows
dude I [ __ ] hate it I am [ __ ] a tit
but I don't ever do it I've done it a
few times and it always makes me feel
really bad but I'm here I'm here I'm
here now for you babies okay I wouldn't
know I don't cancel the podcast we've
gone 86 [ __ ] weeks in a row what the
[ __ ] now did one fire get me a shirt
that's way too small
yeah does it show off my [ __ ] muscles
yeah and is that okay yeah and dude it's
like you know you got it sometimes see
the [ __ ] striations and you got is
sometimes see the [ __ ] [ __ ] dude if
you don't see the cuts what we're doing
it for now I'm not doing it I'm not the
kind of guy that's like yeah I [ __ ]
work out I do work out for me but a lot
of people are like I work out for me you
know and you know like no you don't then
why do you have lip injections why do
you have [ __ ] a fake butt but for
guys we don't get fake butts and
normally we don't get lip injections but
there are a few guys at my gym who do
have lip injections now that it's very
weird to me but it's all good there was
this guy at the gym the other day that
was so I was watching the guy this guy
work out like in a non-creepy way you
know but I was watching him work out and
I was like I was like uh yeah he's
working out his only his leg and his his
legs and his trunk and he was [ __ ]
doing like steps up on the thing holding
the big bar and [ __ ] lunging up and
then only lunges and then working out
his ass and he was doing it hard and I
was like dude that guy's [ __ ] rad he
was killing it and he was doing it he
was like mmm he wouldn't say the full
number he would just be like
and when you got the seven year ago a
like come on dude just say the whole
number if you're gonna do two syllables
with it you know and and it was like
damn dude why is he only working out his
[ __ ] legs and trunk and then when he
would walk away from the the weights he
had the most [ __ ] sachet a smooth
movement and I was like oh he's gay
that's why cuz gay guy I didn't realize
that gay guys probably work out their
[ __ ] trunk and legs like ladies dude
because it's all about that what do you
call it the aesthetics you know it's all
about the extent aesthetics now I'm a
guy and personally moon tracked it to
girls and so it doesn't really matter
what you look like as a guy which is
kind of weird you gotta look a little
bit presentable you got to have some
cuts and some striations maybe but it's
okay if you have a little bit of a dad
bod because girls love [ __ ] Leonardo
DiCaprio and I don't ever really know
him to be [ __ ] finish it maybe it's
because he's rich as [ __ ] and real
talented and not because of his body
right I don't know all I know is I've
never sent a dick pic in my life in my
whole life I've never sent a dick pic
never once sent a dick pic in my life at
one time I heard an actress was bragging
that I sent her a dick pic and if
somebody said to me hey man you sent a
girl dick pic she said you were sending
dick pics and [ __ ] like with each other
you were sexting and and sending like
tits and dick pics and [ __ ] she sent me
and I was like dude I don't even know
that girl dude the amount of [ __ ] I hear
about about me is are is so insane I'm
like what who is that even though it was
had to look her up and I mean she was
hot and stuff but I was like darn never
even met her in my life I was like are
you sure she was talking about me he
said yeah man you just saying you is it
the comedian and say yeah I was like all
right I was like there's another Chris
D'Elia that has a [ __ ] something to
do with the University over in DC or
something and he's 57 you [ __ ] was at
him
like nope anyway that's what's up dude
lots of lies out there you know I mean
that's a lion tamarin if a girl ever
asked me for a dick pic I'd be like nah
but I'll draw it I'll draw it to size
and I would secretly draw it a little
bit more veiny just so when she saw it
eventually she'd be like oh okay
it's not as vain as I thought it was ah
if you're watching the [ __ ] by the
way the new renovations has been going
great man we got a lot of hits on the
YouTube shits and we got a new [ __ ]
design up here we don't have a new
design but we have a new thing that we
hung up and it's a [ __ ] CUDA to
remind you [ __ ] where you came
from dude we got a COO to hang it up on
the right side of my head and it's
probably a left side for you if you're
looking right yeah yeah it would be the
left side so it's on the right side of
my head before you [ __ ] bitch-ass
trolls or like oh it's on the left side
no it's not dude no it's not it's
actually on the right side because I if
you think about sitting in this chair
now we [ __ ] got you dude didn't we
you thought it was the left side but
it's the right side dude it's the
[ __ ] right side dude this the right
side the coudé is on the right side dude
and this is to remind you [ __ ]
where you came from dude this is how it
is full circle there's a CUDA on the
right and we got the congratulations
[ __ ] cult sign right here by some
girl named Katherine I think it's on the
back of it then she put her name and I
didn't [ __ ] look this past week even
though I said I would so I could shout
her out but I think her name's Katherine
and dude this is it full circle
imagine a full circle going out like
that a full circle where we got the CUDA
on the right and then all the way over
to the left you see the [ __ ] [ __ ] you
see the other side of it but it's a full
circle man and we're all up there or
down here and I'll tell you what dude
this shirts too goddamn small and I'll
tell you what even more it's too hot in
here and it's a grey shirt and it's
gonna show my [ __ ] beads of sweat
dripping down my [ __ ] black diamond
it's gonna show it under the [ __ ]
armpits I don't know man uh what I do
know is I've been [ __ ] every time you
know I follow worldstar after they
posted my a minim video I was like oh
that's cool I started following him
and worldstar first of all worldstar
posts 900 times a day which is fine
because I guess they want it they want
the content these people are followed
they got 20 million followers but also
besides that dude I post on every time
they post so much about Takashi 6-9 that
guy and every time I everytime i they
post about Takashi 6-9 I [ __ ] say man
I talk about I say man that I always
write man that chick is beautiful I
always write like god she's really
looking good lately like she took she
took her like every I'll bite I I write
like oh man she because she got she got
her teeth out she got a rainbow teeth
out and I was like oh man she looks good
still but I gotta say she looks good
both ways but she looks really sexy with
the like the rainbow look you know and
and dude the people who [ __ ] light me
up in the comments is hilarious
first of all for some reason this is the
number one comment I get exactly this
you gay just the you and then gay which
is and then some people are like dude my
man that's a guy not a girl oh yeah dude
oh yeah he had a shirt off his shirt off
at the concert
and they were posting a video of his
shirt off at the concert and I was like
man it's so it's so crazy that she's I
forget what put some like oh she's so
crazy she's performing shirtless and and
people just under that you gay you gay
this world is just amazing you to see
that comment and then to write you gay
like they're alerting me to something
first of all not knowing that I'm making
a joke second of all not knowing not
thinking like wow this guy thinks a girl
would just perform shirtless anyway
she's a [ __ ] beautiful girl
Takashi six nine is a beautiful girl
like straight up I'll tell you what man
that girl's sex
he's got long beautiful rainbow hair and
she's got long a really great grill
she's got a really great sex appeal too
and she's got 69 all over her body so
you know she's down dude you know she's
down to put her [ __ ] and face burger
you know where you're you know is and
you know she's down I bet she's a good
dancer
but I will say though it's hilarious to
get those you gay comments what the [ __ ]
I just people on the internet are insane
and we know this and that's not a
premise that is new but we know that but
anyway you gay um I was I ran off I ran
four miles the other day all right now
that's cool now every time I sometimes I
post that on Instagram on my story and
I'll just put like how many like my like
miles I ran or like calories I burned or
whatever and I'll post that on my story
and then first of all people will be
like all men you talk [ __ ] about this in
your last special which is so wrong and
I didn't all I did when I was making fun
of other people who are super
inspirational on on on Instagram and me
posting a picture of that is not that
but people love to [ __ ] be like do
all the park all in the Google block you
know anyway I did that and then I was
like so I run I can run like a [ __ ]
it like straight shot like I can keep
that under nine minutes under a 9-minute
mile if I'm doing [ __ ] four miles
right and then I was like how what can I
do how can I run like what's the fastest
I could run a mile and I it's around
eight minutes like I do an eight I can
do an eight minute mile
okay and then I was like what's the
fastest mile ever ran and it's recorded
and it's three minutes and 43 seconds
okay
so I was like how fast is that like when
you're doing it you know cuz when you
watch the guy do it you're like okay
these guys are probably who knows how
tall they are but they're so lanky and
it just looks like they're just jogging
right so I was like I was like I looked
it up and then I [ __ ] tried to hit it
on the treadmill hey man I can't even
get to that fast dude these guys can do
it for a mile I can't even
top speed it there I can go people are
like that there was a there was a thing
on it was like I was like what is like a
really good fast mile that you can try
and do and it's like a five-minute mile
that's [ __ ] too fast you're sprinting
the whole time and I Got News for you
I'm not Kenyan I'm a [ __ ] white guy
from New Jersey that's so fast a
five-minute mile and I was like I was
like what kind of mile like what kind of
fast like how fast is that and I did it
and by the way when I run when I do my
four miles
I do sprints - and then I slow it down
and then I do a sprint and then I slow
it down by the end of the fourth mile my
back and my abs were like a hug guy okay
we got to stop mile it's not your legs
dude my legs could keep going I when I
was done I was like dude good thing I
stopped my back would it gave the [ __ ]
out dude three minutes and 43 seconds
that's insane by the way if I started
running like we know humans can run for
miles and miles or for you know for
miles if I was the first human and I ran
for miles
I will be like hey everybody just so you
know that's as much as you can run as a
human you
it's bad for the body if you go any
longer than that and everyone will be
like okay so all I'm saying is good
thing I'm not the [ __ ] first human
man I would have [ __ ] we would have
been a bunch of fat lazy pieces of [ __ ]
I'd have been like hey four miles that's
a top speed five minute mile you can go
about you know that's it any faster than
that your knees blow open and your back
gives out and you die you die if you go
faster than that and Kenyans would be
like what are you talking about it we
would have met a bunch of Kenyans anyway
but I would [ __ ] you're talking about
and be like yeah yo you guys got to die
early and then they just keep running
and they never stop
but that's [ __ ] I've been doing that
but going on these hikes to to try and
[ __ ] split it up you know and not
just do these not just do the running
because you know you got a [ __ ] ya
know stay healthy a bunch of different
ways and also if you work out other
muscles then you get going in the
running will be easier and I do hikes
and I dude it is there is this [ __ ]
trail we do that's just so hard and I
know sometimes I do this the Runyon
trail and people are like nice dude
la oh dude it's hard I don't give a [ __ ]
when you say it's not hard you're doing
one of those [ __ ] things that people
do or it's like you're just saying [ __ ]
or you're like just saying [ __ ] to sound
cool we're like Oh pineapple doesn't
belong our pizza or [ __ ] you know
it's so hard it's hard and it and and I
did it and this is how hard it is as a
matter of fact one last time not last
time but one of the other hikes I did
recently I [ __ ] woke up real nice
good or early for me it was about you
know 9:45 a.m. that's real nice and
early for me just when the Suns peeking
out over the horizon 9:45 a.m. and I and
I got up I didn't take a shower because
I was gonna sweat my balls off doing a
hike and it was hot as [ __ ] put on my
shirt put on my pants put on my [ __ ]
gear that I got from by the way let me
give this company a shout-out it makes
great workout gear um a SRV a a SRV is
that what it is
a SRV yep
they make the [ __ ] best [ __ ] I got my
workout gear on from a SRV I put my a
SRV shorts on my ASR VA SRV shirt on and
I went and I went on and I went down to
the [ __ ] coffee bean I got if I got a
nice black tumeric the ice black
americano sucked that down didn't put
anything in my belly and and I went on
the hike and it was tough and I almost
had to use my hands that's how hard the
hike is okay and when I I was with my
buddy Dan and what my buddy Marc and I
almost got to the top and when I almost
got to the top my tummy went over and I
thought huh that's interesting didn't
need anything just suck down some coffee
oh by the way I already went number two
before the hike in my bathroom at home
okay as I'm running up almost to the top
I say to Dan and Marc hey man it's a
good thing I went number two already
because when I get up to the because
because if I didn't I would have for
sure had to go on this hike tummy
responds by going wrong or or again okay
get all the way up to the top of the Hat
oh I went also with my buddy Kevin
Durant not Kevin Durant the basketball
player the actor that's [ __ ] really
good oh no Dan wasn't there was Kevin
and Mark anyway it doesn't matter
he's up my buddy Kevin's on the the the
the strain and so get all the way to the
top
my stomach is going but a lot of rural
or rural or or and I'm like oh what the
[ __ ] dude I know I don't have to go
number two because I just went so then
we start to go downhill and I say ah you
guys guess what think I got a [ __ ] go
number two here on this hike on the way
down and Kevin's like really and Mark's
like are you sure
Oh seriously cuz he always says that
because he's Irish and that's all he
says Oh seriously
and I walk down a few more steps and I
said look guys there's no stopping this
there's no way there was no private area
so I pulled down my pants and I went a
number two right on that hike
and felt great immediately afterwards it
was probably like a four-second it all
just came out when and then I took my
ASR v shirt and that had to be how I
cleaned up
so a SRV I really loved that shirt I
wish I [ __ ] still had it but I don't
and then guess what when hiking again
the next day sure it was still there
there's nothing I can do about that
and I'm sorry and I'm sorry for everyone
that runs by and sees a [ __ ] shitty is
RV shirt but what am I gonna do dude
that's nature baby that's [ __ ] that's
me that's humans in their natural
habitat my babies that's it that's how
you remember that that hike by the way I
haven't talked Kevin that was our oh we
got a catch-up hike I hadn't [ __ ]
seen him in in [ __ ] years
okay let's catch up cool you wanted to
run in yeah I'm gonna be in [ __ ] la
cool cool let's hike up the hill oh cool
no excuse me one second let me just let
me take my shirt off and just there we
go
let me grab one end and [ __ ] with one
fist in front of my balls one end with
one fist and behind my balls light and
clean my taint like a [ __ ] like a
like a jock portrayed in the 1980 show
oh so anyway our cool that was cool
you're on the stream for three years and
were able to buy a house because of it
and [ __ ] white wiped wiped I cleaned
up with my [ __ ] free eye a SRV shirt
so by the way I have a bunch of a SRV
clothing still and I'm gonna wear that I
love that [ __ ] company and thank you
for helping me to because you helped me
and thank God I was wearing a black
shirt too not a white one because then
you know anyway if you're a tourist in
LA and you're a [ __ ] fan of mine go
[ __ ] snap a photo of that it's
probably not there anymore what a
[ __ ] awful awful I felt good
afterwards I was like you know what I'm
close to nature this is how it is and I
[ __ ] and then when we said bye it was
like see I was like Bryce didn't touch
it but we should get out you know see
you later
then drove home and took a [ __ ] great
shower and that's my story
oh it's [ __ ] that was the only time I
ever did that by the way outside ever
there's the only time I ever went number
two outside and that's weird we should
all we should all do that everyone
should have to do that you know my buddy
Kevin he's like I grew up in the [ __ ]
woods in Canada he's like broad
sometimes you just that's where you go
you know I was like well that's [ __ ]
amazing my and then Sasso told me Will
Sasso I told him the story and he was
like that's what I don't know if he was
joking or not I feel like you wasn't
because this is something you would do
it's like that's why I always wear cargo
shorts when I [ __ ] hike and I also
bring a knife so if I ever have to run
into that problem I just cut off one of
the pockets and wipe my ass that way I
was like who are you [ __ ] dump
MacGyver hey who are you [ __ ] bowel
movement MacGyver brings a knife hey
dude I'm gonna bring a knife on the hike
how come case I need to [ __ ]
some backwards doesn't make any sense
Why What are you gonna do stab your
[ __ ] after you [ __ ] now cut off one
of my cargo pockets cool man
hey you're weird as [ __ ] alright cool
catch you later yeah dude and then I
went and I took a shower and I went home
and then I went to go get another coffee
cuz that's how I do I drink iced
americano is all [ __ ] day long dude
and you can't tell me nothing dude
laughs dude i drink iced Americanos all
day and you can't tell me nothing that's
to me what that [ __ ] Kanye West song
is about can't tell me nothing so uh and
so I yes so I went to so I went to get
another coffee this is actually a
[ __ ] crazy day so I went to go get
the coffee and I sat down and I went to
I sat down I was kid first of all I
walked into there to talk about
what did okay so I went to the [ __ ]
coffee bean or know that coffee in a
different coffee shop and I drank the
coffee and I was sitting there and all
of a sudden I saw this big ass bodyguard
and I was like what the [ __ ]
and this paparazzi and then all and
night you know outside and I walked into
coefficient and [ __ ] Angelina Jolie
was there and I was like how hilarious
is it that she's in a coffee shop
getting a coffee with her kids and
there's a guy who just [ __ ] [ __ ] on a
hike with her in there you know I mean
like as elegant as Angelina Jolie is and
his elegant as she she's the most
elegant lady in the world and one of the
most beautiful women in the world and
just like the way she was walking
through looking at the trinkets at the
coffee shop - I was just like oh cool
she moves in slow motion and Here I am
oh by the way
hey hey Angelina by the way I just took
a [ __ ] on the on the at Runyon
outside she made and we
for a second and by the way this is how
I don't [ __ ] you know you I live in a
Hollywood I live in LA I run into people
all the time I've worked with him all
the time like famous people do do I may
eye contact with her I almost passed out
and I was sitting down
that's how elegant and cool and her
whole [ __ ] thing is dude it's so
funny that then I was driving on my
homage just thinking how funny it was
that I went on a hike am i my [ __ ]
buddy from the strain had to keep an eye
out for me while I while I [ __ ] went
number two near a bush on a [ __ ]
highly populated hike in Hollywood
California and then I and and then I
went and then Angelina Jolie was there
and she was had to be the fact that she
had to be in a coffee shop with a guy
that just [ __ ] took a number two on a
hike it just really brought her down a
notch
you know what I mean and she doesn't
know but that's who she is now she's the
girl who has to be in a coffee shop with
a guy who just took a [ __ ] on a hike
outside sorry
what am I gonna say you used to be the
queen of Hollywood you're not anymore
because of that day I ruined you and I'm
sorry but you
cookie crumbles man every now and then
you just get you got it there's a you
know there's a new Angelina Jolie I
don't know who it is now yet but I can't
wait to [ __ ] [ __ ] on a hike again and
have to go see the new one just bring in
bringing everybody down hey guys wanna
talk to you a little bit about me undies
uh you've heard me talk about me undies
a million times but why am I actually so
obsessed with them it's as simple as
this when I wake up in the morning all
groggy I actually get excited to go to
my underwear drawer and pick out which
undies I want to wear for the for the
day and I do do that I did that this
morning I was like well where do the
turquoise blue ones and I got them on
right now as you can see if you're
looking at the video podcast and I like
them I like I like them because they're
so comfortable and they do but they
because they use this thing called they
use a micro modal fabric which is a full
three times softer than regular cotton
you honestly have to try them on to
believe it I know it sounds like I'm
being silly but it's really true it's
unbelievable how comfortable they are I
couldn't believe how soft these things
were it's exact fabric you want down
there in that area and they have a
hundred percent satisfaction guarantee
if you don't love them which you will
send it back for a full refund
and members gain access to exclusive
prints that no one else can get is very
cool I have a few of them they get
special member pricing on every product
Mandy's makes and switch up your styles
or skip any month you want to get your
15% off your first pair free shipping
and a hundred percent satisfaction
guarantee go to me Indies comm slash
Congrats that's me andis calm / Congrats
blue apron blue apron delivers
farm-fresh ingredients and step-by-step
recipes to your door I've probably been
eat I eat blue apron a few times a week
and every time I do I feel good about
myself they give you enough that keeps
you full and you know I feel like it
doesn't sometimes you you eat food and
you're like oh why did I eat that
I feel bad this is like really good food
that makes you feel good about eating it
you choose chef designed recipes they
deliver fresh seasonally inspired
ingredients and you cook incredible
meals in as little as 20 minutes it
takes no time dinner is in as little as
20 minutes let blue apron do the meal
prep for you making back-to-school
easier than ever
20 minutes quick and easy recipe options
with insanely delicious flavors I'm
telling you I've never had a bad meal
I'm telling you I've done this for
months I've never had a bad meal from
blue apron it's all really great whether
you're looking for a quick and easy meal
or for full culinary cooking experience
with your family even blue apron lets
you choose from a range of recipe
options so check out this week's menu
and get your first three meals free at
blue apron calm / Congrats
that's blue apron dot-com / congrats to
get your first three meals free blue
apron a better way to cook square cash
the cash up you know the cash out it's
the simplest way to instantly send money
to friends it's also the number one app
in Finance the cash card is free
customizable debit card that you can use
at stores or ATMs it's linked to your
cash app balance as if it were a
checking account it even lets you direct
deposit your paycheck you're looking for
an alternative to traditional banking
you're not alone millions of Americans
have already started using the cash card
cash app is also the most convenient and
inexpensive way to buy sell and withdraw
bitcoin I feel and trendy get into that
Bitcoin thing man and use cash out 20
years ago something like cash app would
have been hard to imagine and now it's
hard to imagine anything else so there's
never been a rewards program like boosts
get instant discounts every time every
single time you swipe your cash card at
coffee shops Chipotle Shake Shack and
beyond just tap a boost in the app and
pay with your cash card of course when
you download the cash app and enter
rewards code Congrats five dollars goes
to you and five dollars goes to time's
up Legal Defense Fund download the cash
app for free on the App Store or Google
Play market this internet dude it's
still not coming up we got to fix it do
it one fire no it doesn't work
he's like it works for me I'm putting up
pulling up I tried to pull up you can't
tell me nothing
for [ __ ] ten minutes now all I want
to do is [ __ ] yeah uh and talk about
how I get iced Americanos dude I love
that you guys are chillin with me man
listening to me
[ __ ] it really makes my day and you
guys were true babies you really are you
really are true babies a manner that
doesn't work and one fires my enemy
right now but you guys are [ __ ] my
true babies and sometimes you're closer
to me then [ __ ] then one fire is and
I've known him I did I so I did a I went
to go visit so I was in I did a show
with my my Irish buddy at the Laugh
Factory I do shows with him sometimes
on Friday at the Laugh Factory when I'm
in town he also deejays ok at this place
called the den in Hollywood it's a cool
place it would probably be cooler if I
was a frat guy
it will probably be cooler if I said
stuff like Oh classic or talked about
how good [ __ ] guacamole was you know
I'm talking about probably a lot cooler
if I had a backlight and tried to lure
girls into my room by saying hey have
you ever seen a black light but I don't
go out a lot but my buddy was DJing and
I was gonna go pick him up
because we were gonna go eat afterwards
and it was like 1:15 a.m. and I got to
the place and I walked quickly through
the crowd so nobody would [ __ ] stop
me and be like whoa dude and I've walked
in I went into the booth with him which
is closed off and we were laughing
because first of all I was out and
second of all he's a DJ and it's funny
to me because I don't know why he's good
at being a DJ and why he even knows how
to do all that [ __ ] because he's a
comedian
alright but you know what you get paid
where you [ __ ] get paid right you
trying to [ __ ] he's just trying to
eat like the rest of us so so we're
doing it and I'm standing there and
people are like coming up to me like to
what what are you doing here you know
you take it can I take a picture stuff
like that hey man I'm a big fan oh
really
thanks no seriously oh cool oh yeah no
but for real though because when I
started listening to you oh yeah yeah so
I just want to let you know like I
really am a big fan hey man I believe
you stop saying that okay so between
that and between people coming up to him
and saying hey man can you play this
song can you play that song and trying
to put there and putting this guy we've
kept putting the drink on the table and
my buddy mark was like hey man you can't
put that on there you have to you have
to have it away from the equipment and
he'd be like no no no no that's all he
said and he wouldn't do it and my buddy
was like dude he was like pushing the
drink he's like you have to keep it off
and the guy would go and just keep the
drink over the equipment and we were
laughing so hard at what a [ __ ] dunce
this [ __ ] was cuz he recognized me
too and he was like trying to say
something about like man you're funny or
something and we were laughing so hard
and then Mark was telling me about these
times were like one time this girl was
like can you play this song again and he
was like no I just played it and she
goes and spilled her drink on his
equipment now let me tell you something
man
you guys know me if you listen to this
podcast I've done the [ __ ] thing
where I was an open mic refer a long
time and you get treated like [ __ ]
and you know you get rid of like [ __ ] in
the beginning of any kind of profession
whatever you're doing okay if I was a DJ
if I right now I've been doing stand-up
almost for 12 years
okay if I was a DJ for as long as I have
been a comedian I would have already
killed someone and I mean that I would
have [ __ ] killed someone the way
people tree
a DJ coming up dude I would have been in
I don't know how many fights and I would
have killed someone I actually think I
would be in jail right now for killing
someone who came up to the DJ booth I'm
not talking about chainsmokers [ __ ] I'm
not talking about Diplo I'm not talking
about marshmallow or [ __ ] whatever
kind of an Mouse head whatever the [ __ ]
mouse had guy is dead mouse deadmau5 6
lakh but I would have I would have it
would have been the kind of snap to
where a guy would have been like hey man
and put his Dre would have been the
drink thing that would add rum him a guy
keep the drink off the thing oh ok I
can't lean on the tip oh ok baby can't
lean you're leaning on the thing ok this
is our what a snappin ok dude one second
let me play a real long song I'm playing
that [ __ ] meatloaf song I will do
anything for love but I won't do who
that that's like a 12-minute goddamn
song or I'd play November rain from Guns
and Roses cuz it's 11 minutes too long
and I would step out of the DJ booth put
my [ __ ] dukes up like like like a
Fighting Irish and I would [ __ ] and I
would fight that guy mark my words till
one of us was dead and if I was dead
cool I don't have to deal with those
[ __ ] [ __ ] anymore but if he
was dead I'd have to go to prison and
people would be like what are you in
here for and I would be like well I'm a
DJ and and too many people were coming
up to the booth and I killed somebody
because of it that's what would have
happened dude I
believe the [ __ ] [ __ ] in third we
were laughing saw because mark was
saying that people like multiple times
have come up and like just been like
filming him and like giving him the
finger dude imagine that imagine people
just coming up doing that how dude I
would have thought I would grab the
phone and I would stick it in my [ __ ]
and then I'd give it back to you there
you go
make a shitty call dude I if somebody
imagine this is something you see on the
video podcast but he was like they were
they would come up and put him on like
his story like this and be and just like
the disrespect that humans have is
unbelievable dude it's unbelievable man
so great I [ __ ] would it's actually
well I mean we were crying back there
because of the way people get treated
crying laughing Wow Lana no I'm gonna go
to [ __ ] Toronto and London Ontario
and Ottawa for some shows this weekend
they're all sold out I think there might
be a few tickets left for Toronto what I
don't understand what's up every [ __ ]
show I do by the way every every time
somebody tweets me hey man you're sold
out no somebody hit me hey you're sorry
you're sold out in Austin is there
anything in the gig in Austin is on like
December 28th and it's not sold out
there's like hundreds of tickets left
because it's in [ __ ] nine months and
and and then and I'm like it's not sold
out and then she writes back yeah but
well then ticket fly doesn't want me to
come see you and and then I go as a
customer to my own website and I go
check ticket fly and I'm able to get
tickets the [ __ ] slam I did the Grand
Slam I did to the lady cat at Young
Money cat I moved all the way to
Portland to see you in October and now
it's sold out explain yourself and I
write back explain why two thousand
people bought tickets before you explain
why
[ __ ] - I don't mean to get gully but
I have to get gully if you're gonna get
gully if you're unknowingly getting
[ __ ] gully then sorry
but I gotta get [ __ ] gully on you
you're trying to [ __ ] be like cute
with the oh I moved to Portland oh and
now I can't get a ticket
what gives dude I gotta get gully
let me just count to two thousand one
two three four five six seven eight nine
ten good Inga how long would that take
to [ __ ] count to two thousand that's
as many people think about all the time
it took for all those people to [ __ ]
go online purchase tickets do it and
you're forcing me to [ __ ] yeah golly
I'm mr. Kotter dude yo am i [ __ ] it
am i - clown from it cuz you just
[ __ ] put me in the gutter
I'll get gully dude hey Chris you're
sold out how come I can't get tickets oh
you can well I guess ticket fly doesn't
want me - excuse me a second
that's [ __ ] 1295 for your goddamn
all-american slam dude
this is how we do it also you know what
else I don't like is when somebody's
like how come you only respond to haters
that's not true at all
it's not true at all I respond to people
who love to but you see the hater [ __ ]
because that's what people [ __ ] like
and look at and I don't mean by the way
whoops I subtly subtle do it how about
when [ __ ] sticky fingers is like
hurry up man give me the microphone
before I bus in my pants hey what what
you're gonna come if somebody doesn't
give you the microphone
he got probs hurry up and give me the
microphone before I bust up my and my
pants okay well no actually you know
what let's see what happens that would
be me if I was in [ __ ] onyx now you
know what
sticky Fingaz let's see what happens
did sticky fingers was ripped - sticky
fingers is look at sticky fingers dude
dude
sticky fingers you know the name is
hilarious I want to [ __ ] do a movie
with sticky fingers just me and him and
I want to do it a movie with me and him
and I want to play a [ __ ] I mean dude
what is that that's from blade is he and
blade dude there's these pictures on
online of sticky fingers with [ __ ]
swords and guns and it's really weird
it's got to be from blade well what is
what the [ __ ] is he wearing we got to
show these hurry up and give me the
microphone before I bus in my pants okay
now let's just let's see him I want to
see him come onstage if we don't give
him if we don't pass him the mic onyx is
heavy weight and still undisputed what
happened to onyx
they need to do a where are they now on
onyx they need to do a vh1 where are
they now and then we need to [ __ ]
interview all the cat all the guys and
then then when they cut back - and then
when they cut to sticky fingers or know
one of the actually that you shouldn't
interview sticky fingers they should
interview one of the other guys and they
should be like so what happened how what
you know you're not a group anymore and
they'd be like well you know what man we
was in doing this show in Baltimore and
it was going pretty fly and somebody
dumped [ __ ] up and they didn't pass
the microphone - sticky fingers in time
and you know how that go he busted his
pants he just started coming and stuff
and then it was really weird because
like people thought it was like odd that
he was all being you know sexual and
full of calm on stage and even though he
was wearing all black because that's all
he ever wears you could still kind of
see to come and so anyway ever since
then it just was kind of weird and then
it cuts to sticky fingers and it alike
so was what [ __ ] that other guy said
correct he was like yeah you know I was
on stage and I was just like waiting for
the microphone it was my turn and I was
like you know they didn't pass it over
and I just started coming man I busted I
busted in my pants like I said I would
you know I never sits down you know and
then that's it
man vh1 where are they now to imagine
being an artist and and being like oh
okay
I'll do it where are they now you know
I'm talking about like hitting it
having the [ __ ] few singles or one or
two or three singles that just [ __ ]
people worship and then just like 12
years later VH it's like your phone's
not ringing in all of a sudden you're
like what the [ __ ] and you get hello hey
what's up it's your agent for some
reason you have one and we vh1 wants to
do a where are they now on you well how
much of a [ __ ] you from the universe is
that and then - not only that but you
you swallow it and you're like okay and
then the vh1 guy you're sitting there
like so where the [ __ ] you been man and
you got to talk about I do real estate
now I do real estate and long in in in
Long Island oh okay drummer from the Goo
Goo Dolls I mean not the daytime in the
richer than ship I I've no I don't have
a better example okay guy from the
pretenders
I guess he's walking [ __ ] 500 miles
for real now do my brother loved that
song and I will it'll walk 500 miles and
I will it'll walk 500 more guess why I
don't like that lyric that's why I don't
like that lyric you're true babies would
know because that's a thousand goddamn
miles and just sing that I will walk
1,000 miles and that's how many miles
I'll walk and at that I would like the
song if it was that
but don't [ __ ] add you you're you're
making a song longer than it needs to be
you that's a thousand miles you [ __ ]
[ __ ] also are I'm assuming their
songs about love right
so he's like okay I'll walk 500 miles
and then when he gets there I'll be like
okay I'll do 500 more for you which is
like some [ __ ] [ __ ] dude walk a [ __ ]
know how long you'll walk for your love
don't get halfway and then be like
alright I'll walk 500 more you [ __ ]
[ __ ]
you love her or not I will walk 500
miles and I would walk 500 more just to
be the man who walked a thousand miles
to fall down at your door nope
[ __ ] that if I was a girl and he was
trying to get in my pants I will be like
hey man figure out you should you you
should have figured out before him man
you're bad at you're bad at [ __ ]
knowing how many miles you'd run or walk
for me I used to know a guy who who what
9/11 happened and he wanted to for
charity wha a walk from LA to New York
and and he and he came to me and was
like will you help me and I was like
what do you mean and he was like well I
want to I want to film something and
send it to like The Tonight Show and
like Good Day LA and all these places
you know hopefully get some press on it
and I'm just gonna walk from LA to New
York and I was like what he's like yeah
I'm gonna carry the flag he was gonna
carry the flag that does a thing for
America now I couldn't believe that he
was gonna do that okay no I don't know
when to tell you this Park this is the
best part I'm gonna wait to tell you
this part but the so he's like yeah I'm
gonna do it and I was like when you
gonna do it and he said next week and I
was like but you don't work out and he
was like I could do it I feel if I run a
hundred miles a day I'll do it and I was
like you don't run any miles a day and
he was like yeah but I'm young I'm in
shape that's how we sounded
and and he looked just like Tom Cruise -
which is he the best part and he was
like and he was so I filmed this thing
this poem that he wanted to do and the
poem was basically just like I am young
and I am old I'm fast and I am slow I'm
[ __ ] tall and it's just whatever you
would say then say the opposite and
there was an American flag in the
background I mean it literally looked
like a [ __ ] terrorist video and then
he had me drop oh and then that I before
he went I was gonna drop him off at the
beach
this is [ __ ] hilarious I was gonna
drop him off at the beach and and the
night before he was eating Carl's jr. he
was eating a [ __ ] Carl's jr. burger
and fries and I was like hey dude you
shouldn't eat that if you're going to
walk 3,000 miles tomorrow hey you
carry a backpack and an American flag
3,000 miles in eight hours
and he was like oh it's fine the next
day came we mailed the mail those tapes
out to the tonight show there were VHS
by then by the way it would you know way
earlier before the [ __ ] cell phones
got all high tech and smartphones and
[ __ ] and then I went and we were driving
him to the beach and he had his American
flag and a shirt that said freedom on it
that he drew made him look more like a
[ __ ] goddamn terrorist and a backpack
and he was like uh we at the where the
110 and the ten connected he was like we
don't have to go all the way to the
beach just drop me off here and I said
on the freeway and he was like yeah and
I was like all right I [ __ ] pulled
over he got out of my car with his
backpack full of waters and his shirt
that said freedom on and an American
flag and [ __ ] started walk
east on the freeway and as I drove away
I watched him and I was oh and here's
the part I was saving he's Canadian he's
Canadian he is not American he was like
I got to do this for the America okay
now the end of the day he called me and
he was like I was like hey man say hey
dude went pretty well I was like where
are you
and he said Arcadia place called Arcadia
dude he walked to our Cadia the the
first day it's like [ __ ] 35 miles
away and I was like oh well that's not a
it's short for a hundred mile a sort of
100 miles right you can do that a day
and he was like yeah but you know I
don't know it's first day so then I
didn't talk to him for a bit I have
joked I was like you want me to come see
you I'll be there in 20 minutes and then
I don't know the next day I think like
very early on okay
I can't believe this is what he wanted
to do but he got a b got a he like two
or three days in he he found a bike and
started cycling and then the bike broke
obviously I don't even think he got out
of California and then and then he
started hitchhiking and he hitchhiked
and he got to New York in two weeks from
hitchhiking imagine picking up a guy who
wrote freedom on his shirt holding an
American flag
Oh God what what the [ __ ] did parents
think anyway he got it and then and then
yeah like a year later yeah it was a
year later on the on the anniversary
like somebody got so much credit for
like biking from LA to New York and it
wasn't him dude it was so funny man I
don't want to say his name cuz you guys
are [ __ ] bombard him but - god damn he
was so it was so funny dude I would tell
that story to my parents every time we
got together they would be crying
it took him [ __ ] two weeks and he
hitchhiked and he didn't wait you didn't
run him out a hundred miles a day here
in the most he ever ran was the first
day he went there hey Arcadia God that
guy was funny man I don't I haven't
talked to in 10 years look just like Tom
Cruise everyone would be like are you
Tom Cruise anybody by the way it was six
to maybe like I'm Way taller people
would get pictures with him and [ __ ]
[ __ ] people are so [ __ ]
and so weird you know I remember when he
got to New York
he took the flag that he brought and he
gave it to one of the fire I mean you
know [ __ ] great intentions and a
great means well you know gave gave to
the flag to the fire department and told
him about that his travels and then that
guy his stories though you know guys
like that have stories I don't do [ __ ]
like that and I don't really have many
stories my stories are about those guys
you know I can't believe I've lived it I
was living in Burbank and he was staying
with me [ __ ] Burbank dude I if
somebody asked me to do that now I would
be like are you [ __ ] know get someone
out take an uber dude there's no way I'm
dropping you off to your certain death
he said once he was in like a desert
walking his bike and this big-ass
tarantula [ __ ] walked by like I just
would no way dude there was a [ __ ]
brown recluse in my house the other day
and I [ __ ] I had to kill it with my
new shoes by the way these ones these
Gucci wants and I [ __ ] was like dude I
didn't even try them on yet and I was
gonna I was gonna kill the spider with
them and I was like this is gonna be I
hope they fit and I did it
do it spiders are so scary to me I used
to have an ex that would just pick him
up and take him outside like yeah what
like it was a [ __ ] suitcase but it's
a spider sup CUDA what's up sup dude
over on the right side yeah I don't know
your questions here here we go
going to one fire and I have one get rid
of for the questions oh here we go oh
yeah you so many of you guys asked me
questions like this it's so funny like
Rob at the start man the stamp man well
zoom it and obviously one fire what do
you think of people who say Joe instead
of coffee I mean you just you don't have
you probably if you say Joe instead of I
would say if you say Joe instead of
coffee there's a high percentage of
those people a high percentage and I'm
talking about 85% probably don't have a
personality you think just saying cute
things is gonna be who you are
see you turn around uh do your parents
Derek hopefully do your parents at the
shower oh wow that's the worst [ __ ]
that it's actually the worst handle I've
ever seen in my life
you worried I definitely in a frat this
shower do your parents ever call you
Christopher
do you serve them up some Grand Slams
when they do no well the first of all
that's my name second of all yeah they
call me Christopher sometimes my mom I'd
say half the time calls me Matt first no
she calls me Matt first more than she
calls me Chris first Matt's my brother
and she calls Matt Chris first more than
she called him at first it's crazy
she'll be like crap Matthew Chris Mac
Christopher
Chris uh Matthew who are you she'll go
who are you Matthew it's [ __ ] really
weird I wonder if other families do that
let me know for sure oh they're both
I've gotta get rid of n1 fire are doing
that doing the shaking ahead yes yeah
alright next what's that
no Jack Jake fine Bom what do you think
about people who call dogs dago's that
actually doesn't bother me I don't know
why I don't know why it doesn't bother
me but that one doesn't bother me
D'Argo's look at the dog oh yeah I don't
know why that doesn't bother me
I think it's cuz of those accounts like
those [ __ ] that dog Oh language that
[ __ ] kills me like hey friend hey friend
looking for a boo or some chicken
nuggets that [ __ ] kills me dude I don't
know why I think that's so funny but it
is because it's probably cuz it's make
it seems like it's making fun of things
like that dog goes to me seems like that
language is making fun of Internet talk
you know I'm saying it seems like it's
less serious than somebody being like
you know some other kind of [ __ ] FML
or whatever even though whatever FML
isn't so bad what is your favorite
memory at the Comedy Store Jordan at
Jordans vegan that's a good question Wow
I have a lot I have a lot I have a I
have a lot okay my I think I've told
this on the podcast before but if not
I'll do it again I have two that come to
mind one is I was at the Laugh Factory
one night I know that's not the comedy
show but this other story starts and I
was doing crowd work with a bunch of
guys who happened to be from
Saskatchewan Canada and I was making fun
of them and this is what I was coming up
right this is not when I was on TV and
[ __ ] like that I think I had been in
some I've been in some some stuff but
they were there they didn't know who I
was and I was clowning on him and they
were laughing and everyone was we were
having a good time in the audience
whatever okay then the next night I went
to the Comedy Store
and it was late at night I was still
doing those late-night spots there were
about you know maybe 20 people there and
I said it's way really dark at the
Comedy Store that those of you that
never been the laughs actors like this
really bright hi how you do in place and
this Comedy Store is this the Comedy
Store is is dark you know dungeness kind
of place that's [ __ ] awesome okay so
it feels like kind of dangerous in a way
you know like a strip club and some like
that so I start doing crowd work because
it's late at night and it's and you know
material isn't really working because
it's late at night and people have been
there for hours so I start doing crowd
work to people I start doing crowd work
to these guys and I'm making fun of them
and they're laughing and we're all
laughing and then I say you know this
this goes on for minutes and then I say
where the [ __ ] you guys from and they
say Saskatchewan I said really that's so
[ __ ] weird last night there were
these guys from Saskatchewan that I was
clowning and and you guys are from
Saskatchewan and they say yeah we were
those guys and so now I start laughing I
was like why the [ __ ] are you hearing it
did you not know I was gonna be here and
they were like no we knew we liked you
so he came back again and so that felt
really good
and then also so I was like well [ __ ] it
I'm just gonna do all the [ __ ] that I
did about two scotch one last night I
started doing the same quote-unquote
crowd work to them and they were in on
the joke but nobody else was but they
were laughing because it was still like
the first time they heard these jokes
about them and so I was doing like the
same thing that I did the night before
with them versus to them which I did the
first night and I start I was laughing
so hard because of it and that I think I
was laughing so but just it just it made
me realize how special like stand-up
comedy could be and how cool it was
because it was not a thing that was
going to happen again in my lifetime or
my career because it was just to by
chance and now it's certainly not gonna
happen because people you know that kind
of my show they're gonna know who I am
but they discovered
that night at the laughs factor and then
came the next night at the Comedy Store
and then the fact that we just redid
this [ __ ] again for the audience there
was just really fun and cool and special
and I always think of that those guys
made my life [ __ ] better in a way and
then there was another night that I will
never forget I'll never forget there was
so many nights I'll never forget the
Comedy Store by the way so these are
just two that kind of mind Brody
Stephens who as a comedian is one of my
favorite comedians if you don't know his
stuff you got a look at him furthermore
if you're in LA you have to go see him
he's a really great live but he's also
great just if you look up clips Brody
Stephens is his name Stephen Brody
Stephens for some [ __ ] reason he's
got two Stephens in his name and he's
this comedian that goes on stage and he
really like he'll do jokes but then in
the middle he'll be like you know I've
worked for this spot I park for free and
[ __ ] like that he's just hilarious and
silly I'm one time on New Year's the New
Year's crowds are always weird and he
was going on and he was gonna be the guy
who went on at the at the Comedy Store
when the ball dropped he was gonna bring
in the new year and he was like and the
crowd wasn't really receptive to him and
he said you guys have to laugh I'll ruin
your New Year's just like this kind of
guy he's really funny anyway The Comedy
Store spots are 15 minutes each so he
went on and he at this time he was going
on a light like he would go on at like
[ __ ] it was like probably twelve
fifteen or something so he was going on
and there were about 12 people in the
audience okay and he went on and he was
bombing because there were 12 people in
the audience and he was just being weird
or whatever by the end of the 15 minutes
he was there had more people came into
the showroom like people wanted to come
in from outside and just be like ah The
Comedy Store let's catch a show he
started doing really well but this guy
came in in the middle of the act and was
drunk and Brody started making fun of
him and he started killing he started
murdering right and now there were like
35 people there and now all the
comedian's were watching and Brody
really started murdering and in my head
I was like this is one of the best
that's I've ever seen
far okay so it came time for Brody to
bring up the next comedian who was rusty
Dooley I don't know if you know who he
is and rusty was there but Brody was
killing so hard that when Brody was like
that's my time everyone was like no no
no stay so rusty from the back of the
room was like look just you know what
you're killing just [ __ ] do my spot
too
there's no reason for me to come up
there everyone loves you why not [ __ ]
have your have another set do another 15
minutes [ __ ] it
so everyone was like yeah do it do it
and Brody is like only if it's okay with
you rusty and rushes like yeah as long
as I get paid my [ __ ] $15 I don't
give a [ __ ] and Brody's like all right
[ __ ] it I'll do another set and
everyone's like yeah so Brody starts
doing this next set now rusty Dooley
said now he's on stage for 15 more
minutes thirty minutes he starts more
people come in the room because of this
you know people like hey he's doing he's
doing rusty set now - rusty gibbon time
really yeah he's killing when Don says
so now the room is getting full it's
like half full and Brody is Bob now
because there's more people in it he is
lighting this place up it is the whole
room is completely turned around and
he's killing even harder and I'm
thinking this is even the better set
that I just seen right so he's murdering
so now thirty seconds goes by now this
guy he's built a rapport with this drunk
guy he's still there the guys becoming
kind of part of the set other people are
involved laughing out the guy laughing
with Brody
yeah laughing with Bodie and then the
next person on because Brody is like
okay guys I did two sets now I've gotta
go I gotta bring up the next comedian I
don't remember the name of the next
comedian she was this comedian that used
to come to Congress or did late-night
spots and she she I haven't seen her in
years
[ __ ] her name is her name escapes me
but she says Brody look just do my spot
- you're [ __ ] killing there's no
reason for me to do it as long as I can
get my 15 dollars I'll give a [ __ ] he's
like no it's not fair comedians work
hard you
earn this spot she's like I don't give a
[ __ ] go and everyone's like literally
like come on Brody come on and then
Brody's like no no no I'm not I got to
get offstage it's not fair I want to let
her do her spot so he goes to leave the
stage and everyone in the room is like
no stay like comics and comics and and
people and the drunk guys I don't
[ __ ] leave like yelling right and I'm
thinking how the [ __ ] is this girl gonna
follow this guy right so you know so as
he steps off stage he stops like he's
thinking about it you know it's like WWF
or wwww whatever the [ __ ] and he's just
thinking about it and then what it
always happens is when bro you took the
stage he used to play this song by
Paramore I don't know what it was as
some [ __ ] guitar there's like the
[ __ ] back in black song that I play
like something like that like whatever
they're big big big [ __ ] hit was and
as he's thinking it over the music guy
hits that song right so that [ __ ]
song comes on and starts [ __ ] you
know whatever that beat is everyone
screaming and that beat happens and then
Brody hears the song and pivots and
grabs the microphone and says you know
what dreams do come true and and he's
like I'm staying and everyone is on
their feet just going [ __ ] yeah and
he does another 15 minutes and I [ __ ]
you not
destroys even harder than he was this is
three sets now he did 45 minutes and I
sat and watched the whole [ __ ] thing
and it was so [ __ ] funny and I
remember in that night I I was I was the
comedian who wasn't on TV who was just
at the Comedy Store and ice by the way
still feel fortunate that I'm there and
I'm just I still feel lucky to be there
but in that moment I was like wow this
place I am so [ __ ] lucky I just get
to even just be in there let alone go on
stage late at night he was [ __ ]
awesome and it was like yeah Haman
people say [ __ ] like this but it really
felt like the only the only places could
happen is the Comedy Store like other
other stand-up are those comedy clubs
they just don't have that kind of a
thing about them and ever since then you
know stuff like that has happened like
you know I've seen I've seen guys go on
late at night and just dick around and
that kind of special thing happened but
that to me you know now also I'm not
they're late at night really too much
anymore because I do you know earlier
spots and and all that and so you know I
always every time I am there late at
night if i if i like if i go eat and
then walk back or something i see those
you know the the 1 a.m. spot with like
Don Barris or whatever the [ __ ] or I
don't know if Brody still is there late
at night but like I see them talking on
stage sitting down to like six people in
the audience and I always have those
[ __ ] memories of when I was coming up
either doing those spots or you know
just having done them those spots and
sitting in the back of the room watching
[ __ ] like what happened with Brody that
those two memories this is sketchy one
thing and that thing with Brody doing 45
minutes are two memories that I think of
often that are two of my favorite
memories at the Comedy Store good
question and those were some loaded
answers too so I guess that's good I
mean we're you know we're probably good
on episode 86 but thanks for listening
blue apron check out this week's menu
and get your first three meals free a
blue apron calm / congrats and don't
forget download the cash app for free on
the App Store or Google Play market and
two rewards code Congrats get $5 and
give $5 - times up you guys are the [ __ ]
thanks for listening always and thanks
for helping me get these [ __ ] wood
planks to build this log cabin do it and
remember everyone has a little bit of
coot in them that's why we got this CUDA
up here right here on the wall but we
got to fight that cool you got to fight
that inner code as much as you can man
follow the lead or come see me get
tickets follow the leader' buy tickets
at Chris D'Elia calm I got a bunch of
places coming up Fresno New York
Portland San Antonio boss
in Miami West Palm Beach Florida Atlanta
Los Angeles San Francisco subscribe to
the YouTube channel and watch us on
YouTube get a look at that new [ __ ]
renovation in the studios subscribe rate
and review the show please we're getting
more hits and views than ever so we
really love that we want to build this
[ __ ] thing and build this cult
so this cult can end up taking over man
and you can get there's new merch coming
soon not new merch but uh there's a
brief stock in these [ __ ] Grand Slam
teas you guys this [ __ ] thanks very much
sayonara my babies
[Music]